when working with a bandsaw don't cut
your fingers off
[Music]
the redwood
it's vip time here at corridor digital
andrew ryan bacon eagle productions
calvin kingdom john welch so-so is hero
adam j tilly and of course the wonderful
james bailey thank you guys so much if
you guys like our videos and are looking
to support us consider patreon for just
one dollar a month you can enter into a
merch raffle and win a free t-shirt
should we just should i sign this and
just give it to him you could win this
shirt right here
this shirt right there
the month of october october he runs
around he's got a big mouth i know he
trains hard he's got himself into this
championship position but between me and
october i gotta tell you he's gonna lose
wrong bit carmichael you're the wrong
bit the wrong bit man what are you
trying to do i'm taking this door off
i'm taking the whole door off yeah man
by the whole door we got to replace the
doorknob you don't have to take the
whole door off for that we have to
though jake wants me too
yeah it's more it's more secure
[Music]
even before the month begins this friday
september 30th we're shooting a wizard
battle how many permits did you have to
get for this video two because we're
lighting off fireworks nico out of town
for a week gonna throw the streamy
awards at us then he's gonna throw a
wedding at me barrett's gonna be the
production manager for wizard battle
he's got my boy ren in a strangle right
now to get this gta video done because
that's coming out a week from monday i'm
not even i'm not even halfway through
the month yet
there's supposed to be a top part to
this the screw can go in here and stick
in there but when it's just like that
there's nothing for the screw to grab on
to is getting a new door an option it's
always an option look through this hole
all right wren you look through it huh
oh my god
i feel violated cosmo video that we shot
last saturday that's due on the 21st
during that same week on 10 14 we have
another shoot which is for our friend
adi shankar there are 12 stunt actors
location any costumes for all of them
nico wants to shoot this nerf overwatch
video that's three days of filming sam
and nico are going into pre-production
on this lifeline series for youtube red
photography for lifeline begins on
october 31st after that
we're shooting a digital commercial
minor note here on the 30th my
daughter's due
october he's going to try to it's going
to try to bog you down in trying to
think of all the things at once this is
what it's all about right here
[Music]
a word of advice if you're looking to do
something with tools only attempt if you
have the right tools because if you
don't have the right tools you're just
going to waste your time and you're
probably going to mess up whatever it is
you're trying to do
[Music]
[Music]
dude what am i supposed to do with that
contact cement oh no
jake it says wood on it
[Music]
[Applause]
nope
start over super heavy duty plywood
this is an inconvenient time to be doing
this what if you're hanging out in two
hours and i haven't said a reminder
message yet not what i wanted to be
doing right now but apparently no one
knows how to do carpentry around here
other than me
hey ben we need your help
uh
yeah
my patreon hangout within a couple hours
no reminder email has been sent out
i don't have i mean so you want me to do
that yes i don't have any access to any
of that i think it's possible that you
can spend like three minutes real quick
to send out a patreon reminder
yep
[Music]
the reminder's been sent
putting in the deadbolt
my big digital world
[Music]
i'm over my anger about
but this lock i don't know what they
were thinking with the hardware design
on this i happen to have a longer screw
yeah it's going yeah yeah it looks nice
literally a millimeter too short
okay so it's
there you go
[Music]
can you hear that
the the wood is not being held together
by the glue
there you go
good as new
only attempt if you have the right tools
you're just going to waste your time and
you're probably going to mess up
before i put this up i'm just going to
do this the way with the bigger i'm
using a
this isn't meant for this drill this is
meant for drilling into concrete
stupidest endeavor and at the beginning
of this i said don't do it unless you
have the right tools well
this is why
man
[Music]
[Music]
i get to do this all over again
do
[Music]
i tried to put this little bracer in
here to replace this bit i think i
actually finally got it
oh we got a fancy
you just put it upside down we can
always push the numbers upside down no
that's not what's the fun in that
there we go this goes under this goes
look at that that's the thing of beauty
right there i'm proud of everybody in
the office
except for run except for rent ready
[Music]
[Music]
he's gonna try to it's gonna try to bog
you down and trying to think of all the
things at once this is what it's all
about right here
[Music]
i don't know